do you remember my personal site from
the beginning of the first lesson well
it looks like there are some issues with
it when I opened it up to test on mobile
in this case a nexus 5 it looks awful
see how I have to scroll back and forth
to see the whole page page defaulted to
desktop resolutions which does not look
so awesome on this mobile viewport for
this quiz open up this site with mobile
dev tools out of viewports so that it
doesn't look totally awful you will know
you've done it correctly when the page
actually fits when you try to emulate a
mobile device additionally when you've
set the viewport correctly a code will
be displayed type it in below to
continue